- Good afternoon everyone.
Welcome to the first piece
of programming from the Yale Program,
the Study of Antisemitism
in the spring 2024 semester.
I'm David Walsh.
I'm the postdoctoral associate
at the program for the
study of antisemitism,
and I want to welcome this
afternoon Magda Teter,
who will be giving a talk, antisemitism
and racism, a shared history.
Just introduce Professor Teter briefly.
She is the Professor of History
and Shvidler Chair of Judaic
Studies at Fordham University.
She's the author of "Jews and
Heretics in Catholic Poland",
"Sinners on Trial",
"Jews and Sacrilege
after the Reformation",
"Blood Libel on the Trail
of an Antisemitic Myth",
which won the National
Jewish Book Award in 2020.
It's fantastic book.
I highly recommend it to you all.
And most recently, "Christian
Supremacy Reckoning
with the Roots of
Antisemitism and Racism",
which was published in 2023.
Professor Teter has received fellowships
from the John Simon Guggenheim
Memorial Foundation,
the Harry Frank Guggenheim Foundation,
the Harvard Radcliffe Institute,
the Coleman Center at the
New York Public Library,
the National Endowment for the Humanities,
excuse me and others.
Professor Teter is currently the president
of the American Academy
of Jewish Research.
So we are very, very pleased
and very honored that she's with us today.
And Professor Teter, please make it away.
- Thank you so much for having me.
I'm delighted to be with you to today
and to share my work
and my screen with you.
So let me do that.
So let me first say a few words about
how this book came about,
because I was trained as a historian
of Jewish history, a Jewish experience.
My early work is in
Eastern Europe, Poland,
Polish Lithuanian Commonwealth.
And then I expanded a
little bit geographically,
but this book really is one
that reaches across fields.
And one of the reasons why
I was, I've been thinking
that we need to rethink
and find new approaches to
the study of antisemitism is
that I've been frustrated
with the historiography
of antisemitism.
Scholars have been debating over
definitions over spelling,
what time periods,
what's the difference between
anti Judaism, anti-Jewish Jew,
anti Judaic antisemitism, Judeophobia.
Is now, we're obviously
discussing the question
of anti-Zionism and antisemitism.
Is this eternal hatred?
Is it a modern phenomenon?
And the these debates, you
know, producing lots of books
and articles and and
scholarly conversations
have never sort of failed
for me, that they are really,
really getting us somewhere.
And I'm not the first one.
David Engel just told us to
get rid of all the definitions
and move and discuss what
was really happening.
And then I had this sort of revelation
in 2016 when I was at the premier
of Raoul Peck's film,
"I Am Not Your Negro"
in which he play has this
clip of James Baldwin
and the PBS program, "The
Negro and the American Promise"
in which Baldwin uses the N word
very emphatically and very
consciously, I will not use it.
But saying, essentially
asking why is it, why was,
why it was necessary to have
the N in the first place?
Because I am not an N.
I am a man.
And if you think that I am N
it means that you need him.
And if you, and I'm not the N here,
then you and you invented him,
you, the white people invented him,
then you have to find out why.
And that when I saw the scene,
it was this big revelation
and said, this is exactly like the Jew
invented by Christians.
And just to give you a sense
of both what Baldwin meant
and what I mean by the sort
of caricature of a person,
of an image that doesn't really exist
and has nothing to do with the living
either in James Baldwin's
place, black people
or Jews in the case of the Jews.
So the example of the, the N
and the creation of that
caricature in contrast
to whiteness is, are
some of the illustrations
in a very, in a book
that actually argued for
against their humanity
of black people here.
And here's another example,
juxtaposing the, you know,
white bodies against the
caricature black body.
And here is an example of a,
this is a Nazi children's
book of the contrast
between the Aryan German and the Jew.
Here is Fagan from, from "Oliver Twist".
And again, you can sort of see the girl
and the aesthetic of the girl
versus the representation
of the Jew and very similar terms
of presentation and contrasting.
So I've been reading
and learning about black history
and American history
just for my own interest
because again I grew up in Europe
and then I was trained
in the United States in Jewish history.
But on my own I was
reading on black history.
And one of the things that kept,
I kept marking on the margins of the books
that I was reading is similarities between
the way black people were
discussed or described
or ideas that were associated with.
And with that what was with Jews.
So we have, both of them
were obviously cursed by God
for different reasons, both
serve as these contract,
contrast figures constituted
either in the case
of black people, of white identity
or in contrast of Jews, really important
and constitutive to Christianity
and Christian deity.
Both were seen as lazy
for different reason, but
both at the expense of,
of, in Jews case the Christians
and in the case of black
people the white population.
They were both seen as in different ways
as arrogant, insolent or uppity
in moments when they were
trying to assert the rights
or their dignity.
They were both in modern
times seen as ineligible
for citizenship because of,
and this is for the people generous
and willing eventually to maybe grant Jews
and black people citizenship for,
after centuries of oppression
and this sort of uplift persuasion idea.
Both were discussed as a
question, as a problem.
And in the modern times they were both
refused to be accepted as equal citizen.
And when the law changed
and both eventually reluctantly
were accepted as citizens,
there was an immediate backlash.
So, and they were both
also in terms of the,
seen as carnal and dangerous.
And here I'm going to show you a couple
of other images here.
Here are some images of the
lecherous dangerous black man,
dangerous to white women.
And there is an example of those images
of the lecherous Jew.
And again, in case of Black Americans,
we know that this often
ended in lynchings.
The one case we know of
similar dynamic in America
of Leo Frank was also related to that.
But in Europe, that dynamic
was seen in different ways
and expressed in violence
also in different ways.
So in that, in my, in both
sort of seeing these parallels
and in my frustration with the field
of antisemitism studies,
I've been sort of searching
for understanding.
And I thought that the
parallels are so uncanny
that they needed some explanation.
And the longest hatred
idea that that has been
so dominant in the
scholarship on antisemitism
or the modernity of antisemitism
did not quite feel satisfying.
So as I've been teaching
and again, the value of
comparison was actually
again, not something that
I invented W.E.B Du Bois
after visiting Europe several times,
and then the Warsaw Ghetto 1948,
he wrote his essay on "The
Negro and the Warsaw Ghetto"
in which he highlighted the
value of his experiences
that it helped him not
so much give him not so
much clearer understanding
of the Jewish problem in
the world as it was a real
and more complete understanding
of the Negro problem.
So for me, engaging with
black studies has given me,
I think a clearer understanding
of the Jewish experience
and Jew and antisemitism
or anti-Jewish animus
by engaging and thinking along the way
and reading about anti-black racism.
In the '30s and 40's other scholars,
both Jewish and black intellectuals
were making connections
between the two in essays
and in case of some of black intellectuals
to draw attention to what was happening
to black people in America
through the experience
and concern that was raised
about the Nazi treatment of Jews
before the Holocaust
in the 1930s especially
and then afterwards.
In 1948, a really wonderful film,
"Strange Victory" by Leo Hurwitz,
which I call a poetic meditation
on racism and antisemitism.
And I know that seems strange,
but it's a really poetic film
that brings these two together
and sort of combines the
both the experience in Europe
and the current, what was
current in 1948 experiences
of black Americans,
and also the persistence of
antisemitism in America as well.
So one of the ways that thinking
and reading about racism is that
it often focuses on structures on law,
on oppression coming not just from ideas
and culture, although
culture is in broadly,
but also from within the role, the law
and again, structural racism plays.
And that is always seen in the context
of power and oppression.
And here that help me think through
some of the languages
and hierarchies that emerge in the
Christian theology first about Jews,
but then later on have an impact on law
and legal framework
and legal position of
Jews in both pre-modern
and modern period.
So let me flesh out the theology,
and I'm not going to be looking actually
with the traditional texts that focus
on the crucifixion or Judas
or other parts of the
Christian scriptures,
but actually on Paul and his letters,
because to me they play a crucial role
in the later on framing
of social hierarchies
and habits of thinking about
Jews and also legal frameworks.
So Paul establishes a hierarchy of values
by juxtaposing law that for him is Judaism
and faith that for him is
this emergent Christianity
and uses the framework of the
two sons that Abraham had,
Ishmael and Isaac, one as
he says by a slave woman,
the other by a free woman to cast them
as types for Judaism and Christianity.
So one, the child of a slave
born according to flesh
and the other child of the free
woman born through promise.
So Ishmael through flesh
from a slave woman from Hagar
and Isaac from a child of promise.
And he says there are two
symbols of the two covenants,
Mount Sinai Judaism bearing
children for slavery.
And Hagar now is, that is the Hagar
and then the present Jerusalem
is the present Jerusalem in slavery
and Jerusalem above is the free woman.
And that is Christianity.
So freedom is associated
with Christianity,
slavery and servitude with
Judaism and Jerusalem.
And a again, he returns to it.
This means that not the
children of the flesh
who are the children of God,
but the children of
promise that is not Jews
who are observing the commandments of God
as they were given, but the newly forming
Christianity through faith and promise.
And then he uses in a
totally non-social meaning,
but in a theological meaning, a phrase,
the elder shall serve the anger,
which comes from the book of Genesis,
which will really contribute
to the creation of legal
hierarchies in Christian Europe.
There were, I'm jumping
centuries in the book,
I do a little bit more detail,
but Augustine returns to
the motive of the contrast
between carnality and spirit flesh
and spirit and promise
and flesh and so on.
And elaborates more on the different pairs
of the brothers in the Bible.
And goes on to detail to explain the verse
what now at the time where he lives,
which is when the Roman
empire is now a formerly
Christian empire, what in
his new historical context,
the elder shall serve the younger means.
So he says, in the city of
God as to the statement,
the elder shall serve the younger scarcely
among anyone must think,
understands it in any other
way than the elder people
of the Jews should serve the
younger Christian people.
And then again, he returned
what could be clear
that the reference of the two promises
is that the people of Israelites
and to the whole world, the
former according to flesh,
and the letter according to faith,
again here returns to those concepts.
But that idea of Jews
serving the younger people,
the Christians, and the idea
that the primacy has been
transferred to Christians now
begins to be slowly translated
into legal framework as well.
So here what we saw just
before is that a theological concept
of secessionism were Christianity replaces
Judaism and Israelis and Jews
in from the chosen people of God.
And then here we begin to have the rise
of Christian supremacy.
In the book, I'm very specific
that I use the word supremacy
in a formal legal way
as meaning power and authority.
And that's what I see
transforming theology
into Christian supremacy,
into political power when a Roman empire
becomes Christian and begins
to implement certain ideas into law.
So here I'll give you one example,
but there are others of
how the social hierarchy
is now embedded in law and Jews,
as far as I know, the only group
that is singled out for its ethnicity
or specificity in law to
prohibit certain things.
And here is a law that prohibits Jews
owning a Christian slave
and to convert from a Christian to a Jew.
This is ostensibly about conversion,
but there is no prohibition
of Jews owning any slaves
or Christians owning Christian slaves.
So that's the first significance
and differentiation.
And later on it will be transformed into
also discourse of power.
There are other laws
that are gradually in the Roman
Christian empire introduced,
Jews not being able to hold public office,
restrictions on Jews' witnesses
and so on and so forth.
The this language then again,
I do a little bit more detail in the book,
but this language then gets
transformed and introduced
and included in canon
long in the 13th century.
And it is much more
couched in a theological
explanation returning to
the question of crucifixion.
And that is that Jews are punished
and are by for their
role in the crucifixion
and the punishment is
the perpetual servitude.
And therefore, and this is the language
of arrogance and insulin that emerges Jews
not to be ungrateful,
to ask Christians not
required Christian favorites
with continuing and
intimacy with contempt.
And then the Pope
asks the French rulers to
restrain the excesses of Jews
that they shall not dare raise their neck
bowed under the yoke
of perpetual servitude
against the reverence
of Christian faith, lest the children
of a free woman should be slaves
to the children of a slave,
but rather as slaves rejected by God,
recognize themselves
as the slaves of those
whom Christ's death set free
at the same time as it enslaved them.
Henceforth the perfidious Jews
should not in any other
way their grow insolent.
And in canon law in church,
it keeps coming back that Jews are guilty
and consigned to perpetual servitude.
They exchange servitude, they
owe that, that they attempt
to exchange the servitude they owe
to Christians for dominion over their,
begin to, not begin,
but you see the language of power here,
insolence and then a
repetition that as long
as they persist in their
errors, they should recognize
through experience that
they have been made slaves,
while Christians have been made free
through Jesus Christ, God our Lord.
And that it is iniquitous
that the children
of the free woman should
serve the children
of a maid servant.
In secular law, it is
translated into prohibition
of Jews having Christian servants, again,
restrictions on how many,
Jews could be witnesses
against Christians
and also the restrictions on public office
and so on and so forth.
Let you think this is an pre-modern idea,
but you here you can,
you can hear the echoes
of that language from 1945 in Poland
just after the war, Bishop
Czeslaw at the meeting
with Jewish community
leaders says, you know
that Jews are talented
merchants, doctors and lawyers,
and Poland is destroyed
and it needs strength.
Why don't Jews do what
they are capable of?
Why do they engage in politics?
Can you imagine what it looks
like when a priest comes
to a ministry and a Jewish
woman is sitting there,
God knows from where
and treats our clergy with
superiority and insolence.
So here you also have a gendered aspect,
but it shows you here
that language of hierarchy
and Jews in a position
of power giving a sense
of sense of superiority,
unearned superiority
and insolence as the bishop here shows.
So what we have is we have
the essential theology
turning into supremacy
in the legal format.
And those, the law ratifies
the idea of Christian superiority
and the social position
of Jews in legal terms
that they cannot do certain things.
There are laws against them.
And that affirms a sense
of Christian domination,
both in itself for themselves,
but also against Jews
and the you know, questions of contempt
and unease with Jews in
any kind of positions
that do not conform to
that position of servitude.
So that's when we have
this rise of the troope
of Jewish power, this discomfort
with Jews in any other
position than the position
of servitude and seen as unearned
and undeserved social position.
This is translated into visual language.
You ubiquitous medieval imagery
of this Ecclesia and Synagoga.
Ecclesia representing Christianity
as this dominant queen
and Synagoga as this
humiliated blindfolded maiden.
Sometimes there are a couple of images
where she's not blindfolded,
but she's still seen as a
maiden against the queen,
queen, Christian Queen Ecclesia.
And again, that iconography continues
and even into the 18th century,
although it does become less ubiquitous
from 16th century on.
So what about racism?
How does it play a role?
This whole thing plays a role in racism
and that comes in at the
moment when Europe begins
to expand across the Atlantic
and begins to engage in the
transatlantic slave trade.
And we begin to see a
shift in iconography,
and I'll show you that in a moment.
But what we see is an
application of these concepts,
of powers, of the idiom of power.
For Jews obviously we
see it in as an idiom
and although in a
servitude and enslavement,
but it translates into
affirming of the lower status
of Christians as inferior
of Jews in Christianity
as inferior to Christians.
And again, habits of
thinking of Jews as inferior.
In the case of black people,
there's actual enslavement.
So it's not the language and
the idea that comes first,
but it's the enslavement
that is come, comes first.
The subjections to enslavers
and the question of power to dehumanize.
There's a phrase in one
of the slave narratives,
the power to dehumanize,
I can put you in my pocket by selling you.
And the black people who were
enslaved had no legal power.
There was violence and exploitation.
Again, there is violence
and exploitation in different ways
against Jews in their inferior
position in Christian Europe,
but here there is this
direct slave, slave,
enslaver and enslaved person power,
violence, and exploitation.
But again, it contributes also to this,
to thinking about black people
as perpetually inferior and
in fact inflicts our language.
The word which is so
ubiquitously used now,
and I urge people not
to use it to denigrate
(speaks in foreign language) in Latin
gains in the early modern period,
the meaning that we use it now
as demeaning, as degrading.
To denigrate to the
the meaning to degrade.
But it essentially means
to make someone black.
So it's to mean to degrade someone
to a black person's status.
And that's why I think we should,
we should stop using this word.
But iconography this icon graphically,
it also transforms the ecclesia now
is transformed into Queen
Europa, Europa Regina,
where she is still the Christian queen
and is, has very similar posture,
is shown as very similar posture as the,
as the Ecclesia from the medieval period.
But now she does not
rule over the Synagoga
but she rules over and dominates
over the other continents.
And again, that iconography
becomes ubiquitous
in this early modern work by Cesare Ripa,
which is describes how
painters should paint
these different figures, but
including the continents.
Europa is described as this queen
with abundance of food,
knowledge and power,
and the other continents
are in various state
of undress and civilization.
But until the 18th
century, Africa is still
not racialized as black.
It was only by the late 16th
and early eight, I mean
the, by the late 17th
and early 18th century
that we begin to see Africa
as racialized as black.
And that is certainly
influenced by the various books
that focus on the religions
and of the book of the
peoples of outside of Europe
that begin to emerge in
the late 17th century on.
This is, again, translate the idea here,
the we see it in law
and we see it in law that
is very similar to the laws
of the Roman empire, of
regulating who can own other,
other people, other
human beings as slaves.
And in the act concerning servants
and slaves in Virginia,
we see a hierarchy of
both race and religion.
So no negro, mulatto or Indian
so these are racial groups,
although Christian, right?
So they may be Christian or Jews, Moors,
and Mahometans that is non-Christians
or other infidels should
purchase a Christian servant
nor any other, except
of their own complexion.
But if any negro, mulatto,
Indian Jew, Moor, Mahometan,
or other infidel should purchase
any Christian white servant
the said servant shall
ipso facto become free.
So here we have Christianity
and whiteness associated with freedom,
but religion and and race are in that area
of a lower area, inferior
area subject to enslavement.
And liberte is displayed
as this white woman,
and again, in a very similar
iconographic language
as the Ecclesia earlier
and then Europa later.
And America interestingly changes race
once the United States emerges
as an independent power.
And America is now represented Columbia
as a white woman compared to that America
shown in the early modern period.
And again that Columbia is
explicitly a white woman
displayed in the 19th century and on.
So what we have, we have
here a somewhat replaced
inverted order, first comes enslavement,
then the development of
the idea of race to justify
Europeans were really struggling,
especially in the enlightenment period
with justifying the enslavement
of other human beings
and had to find justification.
So race became and difference
became an explanation.
And therefore, and from that
emerged the ideology of racism
and the ideology of white supremacy.
Again, we have white
supremacy in law earlier,
but the ideology.
And that again is contrasted,
that order is contrasted
with what we've seen earlier
where the idea of superiority
comes before the actual
law and actual domination,
but none the nonetheless the two converge
in white Christian supremacy.
And for me that was very important
because when we've seen,
especially in the aftermath
of George Floyd's death, all
the, it's white supremacy,
white supremacy, people often forgot
that it's actually white
Christian supremacy
because both the law, the history,
but also the people who espouse it
really do not see Jews
as part of that order.
And we've seen it certainly
in 2017 in Charlottesville
where the white supremacists
were chanting Jews shall,
will not replace us,
again echoing the replacement theory
from a different perspective
and expressing white Christian supremacy.
In the modern period, the pre-modern,
pre-modern period set these hierarchies
and habits of thinking about Jews
and black people as inferior.
And, but these ideas then
clashed with the modern ideas
of equality and citizenship.
How do those social
hierarchies then phase up
to the ideas of equality and citizenship?
And as the modern nations at
the end of the 18th century,
we're inventing the new idea of the we,
we the people and seeking what this meant.
The question was whether
Jews and black people
belong in the new we.
And in fact, during the French Revolution,
the same people that were
debating the citizenship
about Jews were also debating
the eligibility of black
and free black people,
not just enslaved people,
but free black people for citizenship.
So this is certainly an issue.
And Jews by that time
are already racialized
as Oriental and as coming from Asia.
And the question becomes
whether they can not just as,
not just on the religious basis.
Also, as you can see in the
Willhelm, Michaelis text,
the law of Moses, does the law of Moses
makes citizenship in full integration
of the Jews impossible.
I think it does.
They will never become fully
integrated the way Catholics,
Lutherans, Germans, Wends and
French live together, right?
The religion ostensibly prevents
Jews from this integration.
But there's also this
racial, they stem from Asia
and differ from others.
But the issue was not human rights
and civil rights at
some level of residents,
but really political rights,
the equality of rights
as citizens and active citizens.
The same questions were
in the Netherlands.
Do we continue regard Jews
as people, as alien residents
or regard them as Dutchmen?
Are they fellow beings or are they equal
or on equal footing with Dutchman?
And again, collectively speaking,
Jews cannot share in our Dutch
social rights as citizens,
as long as they are Jews, right?
There's this religion, Jewishness
and religion preventing them.
And the one of the members
of the debate said,
well, that we need to decide
whether we in the
Netherlands honor the rights
of men or only a Christian
men, the rights of citizens
or only of rights of Christian citizens.
So again, this is around religion
protecting the Christian
supremacy in Europe.
But there is this element of
racialization already then,
and it will become more
apparent in the 19th century.
But again, these debates over Jews
and people who are debating it,
keep the question of people
of color, black people
as well in their minds.
And here is from the same
debate about Jewish citizenship
in the Netherlands on a
reference to the slaves
of San Domingo, that
it was too fast, right?
Jews shouldn't be given the
citizenship rights too fast.
They should be, the pace should be slower
because look at what
happened in San Domingo.
The untimely equality
granted to the slaves
of San Domingo served to the destruction
of that French population.
And again, it continues that
is a Jew, Christian rights
for whom were these rights developed.
Bruno Bauer, who sees Jews as a problem,
says that this was all,
that debate was really only
for the Christian world, not for Jews.
Wilhelm Marr, the person
behind the Antisemitic League
and therefore the new term,
the neologism antisemitism.
Again affirms that Jews are Semitic race
completely different with
homeland and Palestine,
and then turns into the
question of political power.
And in fact, he affirms that when it comes
to religious persecutions,
I even take the Jews under
my unconditional protection.
But it was about sharing
the political power that,
but that political equality
that in his mind led
to alien Jewish domination.
And he turns into voting
and electoral power electing
the alien he calls masters
and making them legislators
and judges, right?
Jews in power.
Similarly, a German historian
Heinrih von Treitschke
refers to emancipation or the granting
of citizenship to Jews.
And his again, discomfort with
the literal parity, right?
He's, they demanded the literal parity,
but we Germans are after
all Christian nation
and Jews are only a minority.
So that habit of thinking of
Jews as inferior to Christians
that we've seen developing over
centuries is playing itself
out in a new political
situation of Jews as citizens.
And again, Heinrich von Treitschke
also racializes Jews as Orientals.
And that racialization
goes back actually to these
religious debates of the
17th early modern period
where Jews are, Judaism
is typically discussed
in the context of biblical
observances of Jews.
And therefore they are
placed in Palestine,
right, in the Holy Land, not in Europe.
And these books tend to be
kind of proto evolutionary.
They show the evolution
of different western different religions.
And Judaism is always the sort
of proto religion from
which emerge Christianity
in different denominations
of Christianity.
And then there are all
these other non-Western
groups which also have animal sacrifices
and do different things.
In fact, one book in 1705
juxtaposed the customs
of East Indians.
So in India, in Asia with those of Jews
and Jews of antiquity.
And here is a page showing the charming
of the serpents is
supposedly happening in India
and comparing it to Moses and his staff
and the serpent in the Bible.
And that of course leads to
exclusion Jews to Palestina,
Jews to Palestine.
You can see again that that racialization
and the caricature of
Jews as these ugly people
not the Jew, the caricature Jew
that get me thinking
after a Baldwin squad.
So again, that kind of
process of de-Europeanization
of Jews, of seeing them as alien,
as not being part of Europe
leads to that social exclusion
and political exclusion as well.
And if the debate was
framed around religion
or racialized religion in
Europe, in the United States,
that debate is created
is along racial lines.
And here we have the first
kind of genuine debate about
what citizenship meant
in the United States.
The word exists, but it's not defined.
In the Missouri debate.
and one of the
representatives from Virginia
spoke in the language.
This is what, when I
read it sounded like we,
the white people, we the Christian people,
how it is very similar to the echo to me.
Indian, free Negroes,
mulatto slaves tell me not
that the constitutional when it speaks
of we the people means these.
The argument in favor
and including the class of of citizens,
free people of color goes too far.
They of course meant we
the white people, right?
They were European descendants,
so that could not have been.
And again, can negro whose ancestors
were important to this country
and so the slaves become a
member of a political community.
Think about can the Jews
and their law can become
part of the citizens
and equal rights and
be unequal parts as us.
Can they be entitled, become
entitled to all the rights
of privileges immunities
guaranteed that by
that instrument of the citizen.
So what we see is that as
we've seen the modern idea
of equality, ideal of equality clashes
with the established social hierarchies
and essentially they come to
the conclusion that no Jews
and black people do not belong to the we.
And again, and when they do attain
legal equality forced in
America through civil war
and in the united, in
Europe reluctantly granted
through the legal transformations
of European states,
that equality is seen
as unearned, usurped,
and out of place.
And we see this today
in contemporary echoes
of that exclusion in
inferiority and power.
This is a shot from a ad you
can find on YouTube from 2018
about highlighting the
connoisseur of chaos,
George Soros funding the left
and causing all the sort of racial unrest
that draws on an earlier tropo
Jews causing racial unrest
in the civil rights era.
Race mixing is financed and led by Jews.
Again, very similar idea behind it.
And more recently we've
seen it in the case
of district attorney Alvin Bragg
who is black in Manhattan,
when he charged Donald Trump with crimes.
That's one of those demonstrated,
George Soros funds D.A. Bragg, Google it.
So I wanna share a few concluding thoughts
on how thinking and
expanding and moving out
and engaging with other fields
is really helpful for one's own field.
It's very difficult and it's very,
feels very one feels very vulnerable
exploring and a field in
which one is not trained.
You sort of realize how many
things we observe over decades
of work and how you, you
can navigate your own field,
but when you engage with
a new field, you learn,
you have to learn not
just, you know, facts,
but also historiographic
debate and so on so forth.
But why I think thinking
black studies really helped me rethink
antisemitism two ways.
A, moving beyond the
emotional history of emotion
of history, of hate, you know,
the longest hatred in that way,
but thinking along the structures and laws
and oppression and power.
But also, and that became really clear
after October 7th,
is that black studies and
highlight the experience
of black people under influence
and impacted by racism
is the scholars focus on
what racism does to people,
how it oppress, how that
oppression functions
and how it impacts those whom it targets.
The field of antisemitism
focuses on antisemites,
analyzes antisemites think and repeats
and traces the antisemitic idea.
We do not, we have not paid
attention to the structures
of law and power,
and we have not, as
scholars paid attention
to what antisemitism or
anti-Jewish animus more broadly
beyond the modern period does to Jews
and to their experience,
to their bodily experience.
We studied the Jew
and how the Jew, the image of the Jew,
the caricature emerges.
So I'm going to stop here
so there is a little time for discussion
and I look forward to
hearing what you have to say.
- Thank you, Professor
Teter, that was a really,
really fantastic and thought provoking
and there's several great
questions already in the queue.
So for those of you who have never come
to a Yetzer event online before,
please put your questions
in the Q&A chat feature.
I forgot to say this in my introduction,
you could have been doing this
and some of you were doing
it all throughout the talk,
and we have about 10 to 15
minutes, so we'll just dive in.
The first question, thank
you for this discussion.
Can you please shed light
on how Jews of color,
especially black Jews,
factor into your comparative
analysis while being
at the intersection of both
marginalized identities?
- This is a great question
because I think the,
and this is especially true for the later
or more recent, you
know, now a few decades,
but relatively recent in
American Jewish historiography,
the question of sort of Jewish whiteness
and you know, how the Jews become white,
the price of whiteness and all that.
And and I do talk about it
from a legal perspective.
I use Ian Haney Lopez's
phrase, white by law,
that is that in the United States,
because Jews could immigrate
and be naturalized,
they were white by law,
they were considered like white by law.
There were other obviously forms
of discrimination against Jews in Maryland
and some other places.
There may have been even restrictions
on voting in other places.
But from a national perspective,
Jews were, could immigrate and
were considered white by law.
That's, and Laura Lipman, Arnold Lipman
has shown a very interesting
tale of some Jews
from the colonies going to England sort
of becoming certified as white
or European at least coming
into the United States
and being naturalized.
But in a, the point that
I wanted to make is that,
that that discourse of Jewish whiteness,
which I think is very problematic,
is also erasing the
experience of Jews of color
who as the the questionnaire mentioned
are sort of bridging it.
And that experience,
again, I'm not an expert
and I, there are scholars
of written about it,
but they, Jews of color,
especially black Jews
are caught in that, especially in America.
And again, in that America.
It is very different in Israel,
there's a very different
social hierarchy there.
But in America they were not
quite seen as Jewish by European Jews.
And they were not quite seen as,
as having the experience
of black Americans.
And so there is this sort
of in-betweenness here.
- Yeah.
There are two additional
questions that are sort
of along the same theme,
although we might have already
addressed the thrust of it.
One on how black and Jewish
communities can build solidarity
amongst each other and another on this,
the consequences of this shift
in the Jewish whiteness question
and the specific phrasing is in the eyes
of many black citizens and
theorists, Jews are white.
When did this shift occur
and its consequences?
- Yeah and certainly,
I mean James Baldwin
has this famous essay,
and I don't remember the exact
title, but blacks hate Jews
not because they're,
blacks are antisemitic,
because they're Jews,
because they white or something.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Something to that effect.
- Something like that.
From the 1960s and one,
and you know, he's essentially
questioning the position
of American Jews and immigrants
and the United States as
white and what it does.
And there is this breakdown, right?
Even the 1930s and 1940s,
these intellectuals
are engaging with each other
by 1960s we have a breakdown of that.
And one of the questions that I pose
is this is certainly the case,
but why is James Baldwin
singling out Jews?
Right, he's obviously a,
writes in many places about whiteness,
but I'm not, I know he
mentioned Irish here
and there and he mentioned
Italian that, you know,
they arrive and they become
white in the United States,
and all of us actually
become white when we,
when we're filling all of us,
all of us of this complexion
that I have become white
when we fill out census and other things.
The United States law
functions along those sort of,
even if we don't identify
in racial terms, right?
So yes, everybody becomes
white, yet he focuses on Jews.
And to me that also signals
a kind of discomfort with Jewish whiteness
and perhaps an unacknowledged,
and I'm not just talking
here about Baldwin,
but unacknowledged objection to Jews,
exercising the rights of citizens.
And yes, citizens should in America
was framed along racial
lines and whiteness,
but when we reframed
the question that Jews
are coming, as all immigrants are coming
and trying to exercise their right
as citizen rather than achieve whiteness,
that might change discourse.
But then that may also
change the perception
or it may highlight the discomfort
with Jewish equality as well
that I think there's is a
play a little bit in there.
That the fact that Jews are singled out
in that discourse of whiteness
over other groups that are also, you know,
coming and are white signals to me,
there is something going on in that way.
And of course there is these expectations
that an oppressed would have a solidarity
with other oppress and so on and so forth
that plays plays a role.
And there is a breakdown.
There are all kinds of
complexity issues after,
especially after the civil rights era.
Sometimes, you know,
talking past each other's
historical experiences,
the objections to affirmative actions
at some Jewish groups had,
had a very different
historical meaning for Jews,
especially many of whom
were immigrants from Europe
for whom who saw it as quotas
and a potential problem
for black Americans.
Obviously affirmative action
was entirely different.
So when Jews are citing against it,
that feels like a betrayal.
So this complex, you
know, cultural relations,
but also the, you know,
the relations of habits,
of thinking and yes,
racial thinking as well.
- Yeah, so to follow up,
I'm gonna use moderator's prerogative
because this is also,
I've been thinking about
these issues myself.
To follow up on that question about how
solidarity could be built between black
and Jewish communities
in the 21st century.
One of the things that strikes me, I mean,
I've read Dubois's essay
"Warsaw Ghetto" many times
several friends of mine are working on,
you know, interracial and interfaith,
anti-fascist organizing in
the thirties and forties.
And so it does seem like there is this,
and maybe this helps to explain why
Baldwin singled out Jewish people
as the question of whiteness.
There is this sense that
there was this halcyon day
of, you know, genuine anti-racist
and anti anti-Semitic organizing
and solidarity in the
thirties and forties.
Was that just a ephemeral moment?
Is it possible to build
that kind of politics again?
- So there was-
- Or has too much happened
since then?
- Well, a couple of things.
So I think the, so first
I realize I didn't answer
the first question about
how to build a solidarity,
but I think this, your
question as well ties to it.
I think that we need to,
we need to understand sort of
what the enemies are right, in that way.
And I think understanding the
sort of common roots of that,
that it's about power and
domination and how it builds
and how, I mean, in the
story I tell these stories
don't necessarily intersect
at a certain point,
but they run on kind of parallel tracks
because the dynamics of power
and dominations are similar.
It's just that they are
along religious lines
and racialized religious lines
on one side of the Atlantic
and then along racial lines
on the other side of the Atlantic.
And when Jews obviously arrived
in the United States, in 19th century,
or even earlier in the 18th
century, later 19th century
after the re revolution
or the 19 early republic,
they love the idea that
they're seen as equal
because religion is part
of the protected clause
and the constitution, right?
Whereas the system of law is very racial
in the United States, it's
set along racial lines.
And I think that one of the
things that might help people
sort of understand that A, the dynamics
of power and oppression are built out
of the same vocabulary
and the same concepts,
but two, when we have
that the racial discourse
of Jesus white is flattening
some of that complexity.
And at the same time
the denial, oh no, no,
Jews are not white.
This kind of reflexive denial
also flattens some of the,
and some of that complexity
because there is this
legal aspect of again,
becoming citizens and therefore
having political rights,
being able to vote.
And with that comes a lot of,
there is a, there's meaning
to the word political capital.
And when a whole population
like black Americans
were targeted at this franchisement
and we see today as well with
the various gerrymandering
to exclude black populations from voting
or limit the power of their vote,
that political capital is smaller.
And I, in the book, I talk
about the sort of the reaction
and what happened to
the exclusion of Jews,
of one Jewish individual from hotel
and in both in Saratoga Springs
and then later on the Lake Plaza incident
with Melville Dewey of
the Jewish decimal system.
There is this political
capital that Jewish citizens
can use and organize and push for change
that black individuals didn't have
because they didn't,
they were, their voting
and their political power is restricted.
So I think opening up
and having these
conversations is important
on laying this out and
showing some of the habits
of thinking about both groups,
that those dominant groups
that both were in which both,
both groups were well
oppressed in some ways
is also important to understand.
- Well we are-
- Oh, the halcyon
of the 1940s, whether
that was a moment, yes.
So one of the thing is
that again, this comes in
because the Nazis used
American racial laws as a model
for the Nuremberg laws against Jews.
And this is in the 1930s when we had,
when Nazis are denaturalizing Jews,
when they're limiting
the right of citizenship,
when they're introducing
miscegenation laws
and so on so forth,
where black Americans
are seizing the moment
and saying, look, this is what
we've been going here, right?
It's the moment of common cause and moment
that that helps highlight
the plight of black Americans
in the moment.
And certainly Jewish intellectuals
are part of that and they're seeing this.
And then, you know, just
as there is this discomfort
with Jewish power for different reason,
there was this discomfort with black power
when black power emerged and
we see these sort of fissures
and breakdown and again, and some, again,
not all Jews were on, you know,
on board with civil rights and all that.
Some Jews were and some
then left the bandwagon,
some stayed.
And I think thinking along the lines
of both the different views
and not seeing Jews as
a one group with a white
or always, you know, on the side of
one struggle or the other.
And the other thing,
or I had another thought
that wanted to say,
but it escaped me make and I come back.
- Well, I mean we are actually at time.
- Okay, so it won't come back.
- No, but, but you know, I'm on a on,
I'll offer one concluding
thought of my own
that one of the great lessons
of "Christian Supremacy",
which again is a fantastic book,
I highly recommend everybody
in the audience go out
and buy a copy, is that politics,
especially group politics are complex,
but they are sort of
structured and mediated by,
oh no, did this.
Did you want?
- No, no, no, finish your thought, finish.
- Oh, no, but they're
structured, mediated by
received law, received ideology.
We sort of received structures.
Did you, did you remember or?
- Yes, my last thought was that, you know,
in terms of common moment
and again, how our language might careful
is this question, you know,
sometimes black antisemitism
or Jewish racism.
And I think we have to
kind of move away from that
and ask ourselves whether there
is anything particular about
anti-Jewish sentiments
within the black community
that we could call it black antisemitism
or whether it is just
antisemitism, some that,
or anti-Jewish animus that
exists within some group
some members of the community.
And similarly, Jewish
racism, is that such a thing
as Jewish racism or is
its some individuals
who may express racism
or believe racist ideas?
And are racism, is it
Jewish or is it just racism?
So I think one of the
ways to maybe bridge is
to give up these labels
of pathologizing prejudice
by adding the adjectives before them
and actually analyze and unpack them,
whether it is just simply
a form of prejudice,
bigotry on one group or the other
and not pathologize it
as if it was a single
singular of the other.
- Well I think that's a
fantastic note to end on.
I wanna thank you again,
Professor Teter for the talk.
I wanna thank everybody in the audience
for coming out this afternoon.
I especially wanna thank
because I've been looking
over the guest list,
all of my students who
have logged on today.
I said this morning in class,
you should come to this talk
and I'm glad at least some of you did.
And so thank you all so, so much.
And we will see everyone
hopefully sometime soon
at the next event.
- Thank you so much for having me.
Thank you, the students
and everybody for coming.
Thank you.
Bye.